so a new bill proposed by democrats in
washington state wants to create lower
sentences for drive-by shootings the
bill's sponsors say it's about promoting
quote racial equity because apparently
enforcing the law against violent
drive-by shooters is somehow racist
jason rantz is a radio host
in the pacific northwest and he joins us
now jason great to see you how
is punishing drive-by shootings racist
well it's not racist but they say it's
racist because apparently it's been used
to go after drive-by shooters as it was
intended and they just happen to be
black that's the argument that they're
trying to make that's the only argument
that they could try to make but
obviously if someone is white and is
committing a drive-by shooting they too
would be subject to the exact same law
so as it stands this bill basically says
it can no longer be considered an
aggravating
issue concerning a first degree murder
charge now the aggregating factor makes
it a mandatory life sentence without
parole so instead you'd be hit with a
murder one charge and that generally is
20 to 30 years punishment it could be
life in prison but that generally
doesn't happen the funny thing about
this is this particular aggravating uh
murder charge isn't used very often in
fact one of the lawmakers behind this
her name is tara simmons herself by the
way a convicted felon who made it into
the state legislature she said it's only
been used once now i don't necessarily
think that that's the case this is
something that's not very easily
trackable but let's say it was in fact
used just once that literally means it
is not racist it is not being used to
target black people and this would have
zero impact whatsoever on racial equity
in the criminal justice system one time
does not mean it is a problem in fact it
argued that the argument should be that
we're not using it enough
so it's the rationale jason that
lawmakers in california have used to go
about leaving shoplifting for example
and small theft unpunished because
they saw a disparate impact on african
americans punished under those laws so
their solution was don't punish those
laws it's the same rationale here with
drive-by shootings the vast majority of
drive-by shooters are black so therefore
enforcing that law would be racist
here's my question to you jason
what is the racial makeup of the victims
of drive-by shootings
the vast majority of drive-by-shooting
victims are black so if you're going to
tell me that this is about protecting
the black community sorry you're not
protecting the black community in fact
the communities that are being impacted
the most by drive-by shootings which
happen to be represented by david
hackney the other state representative
who's behind this bill who won't answer
any questions about it they're the ones
who have been asking begging for more
help including more policing to go after
the rise in gun violence that south
seattle in particular has been
experiencing over the course the last
two years
yeah i would suggest that drive-by
shootings have a disparate impact on
black victims and i would ask lawmakers
why are you concerned about the
disparate impact on criminals and not on
victims
that's a question i'm not sure we'll get
an answer to jason yeah but you can
search for it and i'm sure you will on
your radio show
there in washington state thanks jason
great to talk to you
thanks well appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else